state cercando anche voi un gioco che
sia fantastico istruttivo realistico e
con una grafica mozzafiato perfetto
ragazzi questo gioco non fa per voi
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo su famigie
il game
io vorrei capire una c'è l'epicità io
sono senza fottute parola c'è veramente
qualcuno che assieme al cimino ci hanno
fatto con limiting già in parte gli
scherzi generalmente qualcuno che si è
messo lì in casinò di tempo per fare un
videogioco su di me se è veramente
fantastica sta cosa ragazze so veramente
come ringraziarvi
mio dio t'altro checker mario che
saltano sopra bellissimo dai ragazzi a
son perdere la canzoncina perché
bellissima andiamo su gioca perché sono
cecio la curiosità a mille perché mio
dio io io veramente quando l'ho visto ci
sono rimasto malissimo
salve si può t park quebec ma che bel
disegno è questo che c'hai io io sono
sonno con un lupo cioè che per lei lo
slider meno non fatemi con tra il
creatore lista gioco perché da reina
abbraccio incredibile tu sei una vasca
che benché beh veramente questa ragazzi
a casa mia ha riprodotto casa mia è
fantastico come state capire dove devo
andare però dov'è la nutella saggia
domanda amico milano che cup che cazzo
cosa fanno
ma sei serio cioè fatemi capire io devo
seguire il cut mario che mi rubano la
nutella c'è ragazzi questa è la cosa più
strana
vabbè lasciamo perdere comunque che ho
fatto perché c'è un troll face però sta
succedendo perché ci sono dei trofei
ragazzi non sto capendo una sega prole
giorno arrivederci e io ho io veramente
non far marchi giuro non c'ho parole
genoa roma tipo
ok perché passata una marca di
dimensioni abnormi davanti a me in
questo preciso momento non voglio
neanche saperlo mi fate capire perché vi
siete messi sotto un pianoforte a io
sono proprio io ero io
una volta la festa alla fine è finito
così mi prendete per il culo ma che
cazzo di senza vera sto gioco ma perché
ragazze e ragazzi è il paradiso
sì credo sia il paradiso faville
chi è questo mi inchino a lei purtroppo
non ho le ginocchia ma lo farei
volentieri le immagini che io l'abbia fa
ma perché grazie
[Musica]
ok grazie ma che cazzo se si dimette
e ora gancia posso più fare totale è
stato il dialogo più fantastico del
nostro geniale resuscita dover uccidere
che di mario grazie a voi sa da chi e
perché levatevi del cazzo perché poi già
entrati in pista quindi ma stai facendo
che fa perché che mario è diventato un
dj all'improvviso va beh se ticket
spacca un po di musica seria scalda zio
attiva se mi serve un tribuna che bella
gnocca ma vedo anche che qui siamo
straconi di frutta io una mela tu hai
due pere e ci siamo ragazzi ma per
genere mi piace gambe sexy la madonna
mia faccia ria la mia fa mi avvio
luca mi piace che questo sia il mio
gioco fantastico se c'è una tizia con la
faccia da troll based è veramente sexy
tranne il fatto che c'ha la faccia da
tutti i trofei però si può fare tentate
la gnocca mi saga ndrink grazie mille
andiamo avanti prima mi chiami spunti
qualcos'altro di strano dunque
complimenti per il di dietro questo
sicuro salve ma allora sei proprio
stronzo ma ma nel cervello prove ma se
sentite scusate mi devo passare grazie
però è bellissimo cat mario visto in 3d
così comunque zio cambia musica perché
gesù santo vabbè lasciamo perdere
con questa è stato fantastico e questo
me lo voglio
ma che cazzo ma perché devo dire ma che
cazzo mitra secondi chiesto sexy uomo
ragazze un tizio sexy a chiederla
sì sì sì giusto pesta questa è miley
cyrus per dove cazzo vai tu ragazze
mario deve rompere il cazzo
non lo so sto cercando di capirlo da
mezz'ora perché mai di sante che miley
cyrus su una palla da demolizione in un
gioco fatto per me mi mancava perché ci
assomiglia troppo a miley cyrus è
veramente andiamo avanti perché mai riso
miley si sta scatenando nel frattempo è
la madonna che corridoio e questo pesa
temi market marino le catene
ok buongiorno mi state dicendo che devo
fare
mario in 3d in un gioco mio non bastava
che lo facesse in the shadow vuole farlo
pure quadra grazie vecchio altri ragazzi
facciamo st parte visto che io so volare
come madonna che sta ti faccio mio dio e
che cazzo sono superman e fi fantasy ma
mi state prendendo per il culo di
vendere anche se una rottura di [ __ ]
come cat mario questo gioco cioè fatemi
capire non ce l'ho fatta perché si
faccia farsa parte a doha ho capito no
[ __ ] ragazzi a fuori di far così
c'è la dolce la dovrei fare se si
trovata già fatto è stato tragico ma va
bene così figlio di tua mamma
cioè è difficile come se stessi giocando
a cat mario ci rende rendetevi conto
cazzo devo saltare in quella più avanti
questa qui perfetto questa di mezzo di
sicuro crolla sporca e io lo sapevo
perché ci sono andato non lo sa ed è un
gioco fatto per me già rendete vico ne
va a cagare di quella [ __ ] amico mio
chiacchierato questo gioco bellissimo
sto fano dietro perché perché hai fatto
il gioco permesso non avrei ucciso prova
ok adesso non proprio perfetto o che a
questo devo sceglierne una che credo che
sia quella più avanti quindi questa qui
sì sito presto presa in un cul a titolo
fabiano adesso lo posso andare qua
perché se non ci arrivo si perfetto ce
l'ho fatta giova alla nutella stronzo
che è successo sono andato nel tubo ma
perché il cazzo è sta roba
ma cosa che chiedo è sta roba
ovvio lo sguardo meno
continua grazie per hai provato
personale fuori questo gioco è finito
ragazze non ci credo spero che ti sia
piaciuta o no vabbè allora mi con gioco
della madonna tranne la parte ricca
mario però ci si può lavorare grazie
grazie di cuore
no veramente non ho parole per questo
capolavoro c era una demo era una demo
quindi il gioco ufficiale uscirà tra un
po i ragazzi è stato c'è io sono
veramente onorato di aver visto un gioco
fatto per me anche se ancora una demo
del video è piaciuto lasciato il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi video trovate una
descrizione forse avresti di scateni ci
vediamo in un prossimo video ecco è
questo è tutto perché hai fatto la parte
di cat mario sono mica aveva il
telecomando giorno ci vediamo il
prossimo video fatta belle ragazze